rehab was something I needed for the
first time since Bobbi Kristina Browns
tragic death in 2015
Nick Gordon her former boyfriend opened
up to dr. Phil about the night Bobbi
Kristina died you walk through that door
and you see her much like you saw with
me it was literally it was a nightmare
all over again
did she have a drug problem Chrissy yeah
yeah it got really bad after Nick had
passed away it's unfortunate but that's
at the time that's kind of the only way
we knew how to deal with what had
happened he sat down with dr. Phil a
head of the two-part special where he
revealed he didn't let Gordon off easy
during their sit-down and I asked him
straight up did you murder Bobbi
Kristina did you concoct a lethal
cocktail that you gave her to end her
life and there are accusations from this
family that he in fact was involved in
the death of Whitney and I asked him
straight up did you murder whitney
houston's and we're going to hear the
answers and people are going to be able
to judge for themselves the credibility
of his answers and explanations there is
a connection to what happened with
Whitney and what happened with Bobbi
Kristina this is all tied together in a
really eerie fashion how was Nick
health-wise you know he looked the best
I've ever seen him look he was bright
eyed he was focused he looked healthy so
I really think the rehab has worked with
him part one of dr. Phil's no holds bar
two-part special with Nick Gordon airs
Thursday April 28th
you